what happens in the shamanic experience
is that the shaman has the experience of
being reduced to a skeleton first so
death a death experience a very
realistic death experience and then the
next thing that happens is that he finds
himself in a place where he's communing
with his ancestor or the ancestral
spirits and then after that there's the
climbing of something like the ladder
Jacob's Ladder se and an encounter with
God for all intents and purposes and
it's very widespread phenomena it's the
World Tree and I've thought about this a
lot trying to figure out what this what
this represents according to a ya coud
informant that's in Siberia the spirits
carry the future shaman to hell and shut
him in a house for three years here he
undergoes his initiation the spirits cut
off his head which they set off to one
side for the novice must watch his own
dismemberment with his own eyes
dissolution to the primary elements in
some sense and hack his body to bits
which are later distributed among the
spirits of various sicknesses it's only
on this condition that the future shaman
will obtain the power of healing his
bones are then covered with new flesh
and in some case he has also given new
blood so there's a death and
resurrection experience that's
associated with this shamanic ritual
we're here in the presence of a very
ancient religious idea which belongs to
the hunter culture bone symbolizes the
final route of animal life the mold from
which the flesh continually rises it is
from the bone that men and animals are
reborn for a time they maintain
themselves in an existence of the flesh
then they die and their life is reduced
to the essence concentrated in the
skeleton from which they will be born
again that's a good graphic
representation of the experience